oh my god oh gosh there it is I'm trying
to get the rock to swallow it swallow oh
gosh
[Music]
hey what's going on everybody for first
we feast I'm Sean Evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings
and today I'm joined by rhett and Link
that the web's most beloved comedy duo
you know them from buddy system on
YouTube bread and as the host of good
mythical morning now entering its 14th
season rhett and Link welcome to the
show
Thank You Sean glad to be well not glad
to be here just we're here I can be with
you I appreciate it it's good to see you
guys again because last time we hung out
we ate the world's hottest curry at
Brick Lane yeah what do you guys
remember don't bring it up rest of your
date when it was horrible
we actually went out to eat at a
restaurant that we have we since went
back to to relive this memory it was
better when you hadn't eaten the world's
hottest curry beforehand and I told Hank
I was like you know what I think I gotta
go use the restroom I didn't see or hear
him in the restroom and then I came back
out I'm like where's Rhett and then he
comes out slowly like the slow walk he
had been in the restroom the entire time
didn't respond to me when I went in
there and said it's gonna be a rough
night for you cuz I had me a new her he
was head you guys ready to ruin another
evening yes
[Music]
so this one is the howler monkey I'm
sorry I was doing this when you ever
good try talking your bull fighting over
there it's nice just a little hint of
spice mm-hmm so we've had similar
pathways into eating weird food for the
internet I always joke that I didn't
choose the spice life the spice life
chose me and I've heard you guys say
similar things about running with the
taste test format do you remember the
first time you ever had to use the barf
bucket on camera it had to have been
with will a taco probably I mean when it
was just slabs of congealed pork blood
in a taco shell I didn't get that you
know what I didn't if no way I got it
it's not never gotten congealed blood
death which of the following would you
never eat again a congealed blood
sandwich
a scorpion the Carolina Reaper well
scorpions easy I just ate another one of
those a few within the past out
legitimately if I'm presented with
because it's like eating a seashell
actually it's just that crunchy and
tasteless
I mean a Carolina Reaper the aftermath
was catastrophic
I mean 13 hours later he was still in
the fetal position on a couch and it we
can in waves it's just whenever my
stomach would like digest a little more
turnover I could feel it was like a
different part of my stomach lining was
exposed to hell yeah and you just had to
you just had to lock down and endure it
there's not nothing that could be done
when you guys look at how the taste test
genre has exploded when are you proud to
be a part of that evolution and when do
you roll your eyes I appreciate that
question but most of the thumbnails kind
of make us roll our eyes but they work I
mean we cover it and then we show it to
you it's not just about frenetic pacing
and making stupid facial expressions
which I mean I'm guilty of one of those
things heart beat sauce that's got like
a
almost like a cinnamon mm-hmm a little
sweetness in there mmm-hmm that's not
bad
feeling my heart so in 2011 you guys
launched a series commercial Kings we
traveled the country and did these local
commercials for small businesses do you
have any success stories that you're
proud of did a business of her triplets
sales after their commercial or anything
like that one of the first commercials
we made Chuck testa what the text is
that the taxidermist
we made him a commercial and then he he
started his own YouTube channel so he
really leaned into his meme yeah he did
totally did you probably thought this
zebra was alive no Chuck testa you know
the crossover between people who like
internet videos and memes like Chuck
testa and people who actually need an
animal to be taxidermy
I don't know what the crossover is but
everybody knows who he is and he's he's
parlayed it into a lot of other things a
legend was born then yes are you guys
ready to move on well that before you
answer my question I don't want to touch
my eye I've got like yo like a I can't
you owe me touch I do I might touch your
eye with this thing is there an eyelash
in my eye
cuz it's like I want it I'm gonna touch
it with a back of my hand
no you got right there I don't see a
lash look look closer at me this eye I
think I think I moved whatever it was it
was just kind of like pokin
hmmm hints of scurvy see guys are two of
the most recognizable faces on the
internet but have also had some
crossover success whether it's this IFC
show or the recurring appearances on
Fallon
what is the difference to you guys when
you put a video up that gets 5 million
views versus being on Fallon it's a
different type of validation The Tonight
Show is an institution there's a whole
history of comedians going on there and
it made or broke their career but yeah
our minds are blown again and again
where no matter where we go people
recognize us just because we're so
accessible thanks to YouTube we went on
vacation and we met a guy in Fiji like
we once we were done with our tour and
we get off the boat and this guy's like
it linked and it has meny an opium
farmer and he watches the show isn't
that nuts meny an opium farmer yes a
shout out to all the Tasmanian opium
farmers
we're big with that alright so this next
one is the son of zombie okay that
sounds more intimidating than anything
so far their zombie is stirring mm-hmm
oh yeah there's an immediate hit yeah
he's got some of Daddy's DNA for sure
smokey mm-hmm it's like the fires of
some sort of dumpster have grazed upon
his flesh this might induce a hiccup oh
that's too hot and too early for that
though it might happen with you
especially I feel like you need a hiccup
um well I'm always on the verge good
mythical morning it's a YouTube
institution more than 1300 episodes in
fact so many that you guys had me drop
in to guest host and episodes so this
wing is for all the fans out there
who've been saying get rhettandlink on
hot ones get rhettandlink on hot ones
ever since we started booth one guest
that we've both had is post Malone and
as I understand it he's such a big
rhettandlink fan that he watches good
mythical morning every day what was it
like to have him in the so real it was
true because when he said that when he
said I watched the show every day and
I've been doing that for like four years
really
puts Malone it's watching our show and
then you know if you watch the show on a
regular basis we feature a lot of the
crew a lot of the writers and other
staff and so he was like walking through
the office and like people are like
sticking their heads out looking around
too fussing all inside so Kevin subjects
he like knew everybody yes when you're
shooting
he's legitimately a fan but what's the
warm-up though mean I leaned over to him
in the middle of it sounds like amen
this won't let you know it's really cool
to have somebody as cool as you like our
show and he's such a sweetheart I mean
he's just a really nice guy so it's also
nice that nice people like us who are
talented and musical oh oh this is our
your proprietary sauce it is you could
already do that
we already sell in your style you could
have said that I don't like to lead the
witness you know what I mean I just let
it be able we're a heat miss calm heat
miss calm to order here's the thing
Shawn I knew that it was your sauce but
I wanted to create a natural
conversation about it to make a better
plug because I really believe in selling
merch even if it's not mine
I appreciate that just looking out for
the wave mm-hmm subscribe to good
mythical morning all right guys were a
very current segment on a show called
explain that Graham where do a deep dive
and I guess Instagram put interesting
pictures that need more context and for
you guys we have a theme as lifelong
friends we pulled some great rhett and
Link throwbacks
okay so we'll show you the throwback and
you just tell us the bigger story does
that sound good
okay all right laptop please sing good
wings guy this is a good viable sauce
you're going back in participial I'm
pacing myself I don't plan on finishing
alright there we are this is a famous
photo from rhettandlink lore after going
to summer camp for a week Rhett's dad
picked us up he's the man in the middle
mm-hmm who's both of his hands are
visible he's touching us appropriately
how would you even say that I don't know
I shouldn't have said that I was just
like who's this weird man in between us
yeah that's my dad
is it but this handsome marshal no the
interesting thing about this is that
after being at Camp Carraway for a
one-week link had not defecated the
entire week
well bloated and we went straight to the
zoo and let me just say in this picture
link has still not defecated so when you
look at that smile just know there's
seven days worth of [ __ ] and let me tell
you it's tough it's tough not to
defecate after a week of not defecated
when you go to a zoo and every animal
you see is defecating you had so much
inspiration all around you and you still
didn't visit the restroom you waited
until you got home but we got matching
t-shirts we could have picked other ones
we didn't have to wear the same purple
gorilla t-shirt but those are the
souvenirs that we purchased that's what
friends do
all right this next one is a familiar
foe it's a black garlic and Carolina
Reaper sauce Oh Carolina Reaper now
here's the thing if I'm smell it you
know once you have a oh man it has a
death smell once you have a bad
experience with any food not just hot
food your body makes a lasting imprint
of it on your brain so then when you
smell it again in my case if I smell
that smoky death of Carolina Reaper oh
my stomach clenches up well a lots of
things clinched up mmm so this is
difficult for me to muster here ooh
let's let you know this is there it
amazes president it's nauseating to me
so you guys have worn many hats in the
YouTube game but I want to talk a little
bit about the music videos what is the
video that was the biggest pain in the
ass to make we used to conceptualize
videos to imply that they were a pain in
the ass to make to help them get more
views like the Photoshop one was that
tough to make was the same principle
that we used for the t-shirt war which
is which also looks amazing using an
onion skinning program basically you
take a picture and then it puts it puts
that picture over the next video image
it like a 50% transparency so you're
able to look at the monitor and get
lined up completely yeah with your
previous pose and so we arty show while
that would that would that would allow
us to take the shirt off put on the next
shirt with the new design and then line
ourselves up and take the next photo and
with the two guys 600 pillows video that
was really complicated because I was too
many pillows well plus we did everything
in Reverse which is really difficult to
lip sync something and then play it in
reverse and have it seem like you're
singing the song proper I'm gonna
tingling from this
year two this year it's like a colony of
ants are starting to migrate from my
right ear over to my left ear while
someone is wrapping barbed wire around
my tongue and yanking you bend the
bolsters and they don't oversell it hot
sauce
sixty nine to ten heat but that's small
that's not possible whatever okay what
pepper is that scorpion and Birds Eye
chilies ooh oh we had a scorpion I've
had a lot of had a bad bad moment with a
scorpion pepper
well that was an allure peon pepper that
was actually the last pepper I ate whole
and raw the first time it was one of the
worst experiences of my life but I was
able to continue to try and these can be
entertaining but a the Scorpion
something that happened something that
shifted I don't I turn 40 but
I couldn't be entertained unless just a
grown man in a fetal position he's
entertaining it was okay I enjoy
thoroughly but it was it was it was
absolutely horrible hard time talking so
you guys have been on the internet for
over a decade strong stacked billions of
views and won countless awards so what I
want to do is throw a couple career
accomplishments at you and you guys can
tell me if it was a highlight or more of
a low-light yeah all right placing third
in the turbo tax tax rap contest judged
by vanilla ice Miley huge we still own
the like bedazzled medallions that are
the turbo tax logo you and actually
placed third
we then engaged outside of the contest
with another guy the winner who was a
flute beat boxer yeah and we did we did
a series of rap battles back and forth
because once he won we we weren't happy
yeah you had to take the crown off the
king right and sit on the throne
yourselves yeah and I and we did and and
turbo tax is just sitting back that guy
is great not paying us and they gave us
a Maddock we got paid in a medallion
we're just setting a high school
basketball record for hitting 77
three-pointers Oh guys started how many
77 seasons and just one season just one
season where does that rank on your list
what mission accom does that record
still hold it harness Central High
School that's I was gonna ask you
does it still stand yes no one's haven't
even gotten close so it means a lot to
me I think it means way too much yeah
yeah I think I know that you did score
two unassisted goals and the soccer game
one time using my left but both time and
then Daniel day-lewis played him in that
movie which was an amazing amazing honor
I would like to recognize the unsung
heroes of basketball scorekeeping cos
right you for the eighth-grade girls to
have the score right yes that's right
you've done your work
I would like to recognize all women's
middle school basketball score keepers
now I got enough shot the layups don't
stop how about getting rejected by MTV's
the real world know what I love that you
know about that was you know what it was
a low light at the time extremely high
light in retrospect might've dodged if I
had gotten on the real world in 1994
that just would have been a bad time to
show myself to the world in that way how
often do people partake in the liquids
by this point you know it varies guest
to guest I just hit the milk I just took
a sip of the milk but there's no shame
in it you know well I'm gonna shame you
for taking all the way I haven't taken
any milk either okay oh gosh
[Music]
it starts to get there's like a chemical
quality to that mhm it's not tasty again
we're into a place that's not about
enjoyment it's good getting hard come
hey we were having fun man
this is a fun anymore this isn't fun
anymore Sean are you rethinking that
milk pledge at all this I'm trying to
get to work and swallow oh oh no it's
going down oh gosh
alright guys you've known each other
since 1984 attended the same school the
same high school
the same College you've made hundreds of
hours of videos together but how well do
you really know each other
are there any skeletons in the closet
we'll find out now and we're doing it
rhett and Link style we've game a 5k
hold ring no no the bucket Oh BFF
questions
I'll bring in my mom thank you very much
bill link try not to puke in this one
cuz here's how it's going down you can
shave me or I'm gonna go we have
questions and what you'll do is draw a
question and then read it to the other
one so link you'll reach in you'll pick
a question and you'll read it - Rhett
Rhett then you'll reach into the bucket
and pull a question read it - link I got
it I'll go first and you'll ask Lincoln
Linc what's your favorite swear word
that you where's your favorite swear
word that you wish you could say more ng
mmm oh say now man
[ __ ] that's tough
did you have a living do you have a
living will and if so did you say I'd be
the Guardian to your kids yes I have a
living will and I'm supposed to know the
answer to this I actually don't know
you're not you're not are we gonna get
into this actually the honest answer is
between my brother and Jessie's sister
they like figure things out and if the
thing that they figure out is that my
kid shall live with you and you will
collectively make that decision oh gosh
hey you're not blood man I need to apply
the gap here to your kids well I made my
will I'm by the Guardian I'm about to
change it exactly what do you say see
you call me your net I don't I'm not
seeing the comedy in anything anymore
well this is a real turn there's two
more wings on this thing uh-huh
Rhett has there ever been a deal or
endorsement that we've done together
where you got paid more than me yeah
with him excuse me guys it's just a
faucet over here okay here's the deal we
split everything 50/50 but for a long
time I manage our QuickBooks account
and there was one time actually several
times where it came down to an uneven
number of cents and I always be myself
the other cent I thought I'm doing the
freaking QuickBooks stomach is not
wanting to cooperate here
oh yeah before we came here read that
spoke we've had an article about how to
prepare for eating hot things even
though we've done it I was like what's
the latest research on this and in the
article is just a bunch of pictures of
you really yeah check that out you learn
anything hopeful bread carb load carb
load before so I had a big one so gonna
go see guys have tackled some big
questions on your podcast ear biscuits
highly recommend to the viewer at home
and to give them a little taste but will
do is throw out some of those big
philosophical questions to see where you
stand now in 2018 and so you have a take
away okay where do you guys stand on
what a burger versus in and out in and
out all the way Texas has a lot to offer
in the culinary space oh yeah and they
don't need to be pushing water burger to
the front of that line no you know I'm
saying you don't have to do that there's
a lot of better it's not good at all
our magicians actually cool no they're
not they're not cool and that's what
makes them cool if you're a magician out
there don't try to be cool just take him
okay if your magician out there don't
try to be cool just be a magician and
then uh what's the best ridiculous but
true Walmart story what the most
ridiculous Momo story is the one that
happened to Rhett when when his first
child was a baby he was shopping in
Walmart and realized he left his baby in
the car okay you make it sound really
horrible okay it wasn't one of those
situations it was an overcast day I had
only been a father for a couple of weeks
I forgot that I had a child if it
happens and as soon as I change
batteries well I went into Walmart to
exchange batteries and then when I
realized that my child was in the car
which is literally like three minutes
after I went into the Walmart
I stole the batteries that I wanted and
put the batteries that I was going to
exchange on the rack and ran out and he
was fine
yeah and so I wrote them all twice in
one day but everything ended up okay so
the Morla story is it's okay to break
the law it's okay to break the law and
it's okay to break the seal because this
is the last dab we call it the last dab
because it's tradition around here to
put a little extra on the last wing you
don't have to why don't you know could
you dab us if you don't want to sure and
I love doing it in the way that you
prefers to a standard little dab you
think I don't want there to be any
unnecessary arguments between the two of
us over how much
yeah dad their image dad was going on
this is it boys this is it it's an honor
to have been here well you know what
depending on what happens I really like
you
hey like you guys - cheers Cheers dinky
dink you think it
[Music]
an extra dab there's a sweetness in
there right but okay that's got some
flavor there's actually your taste
that's a difficult thing to pull off I'm
just telling you these guys didn't pull
it off they didn't pull off the flavor
and the heat at the same time Oh caught
you there huh something a little speed
bump you know what's got a time-release
in it doesn't Ben who's back to you
okay Retton leak here we are at the end
of the line our mouths are on fire and
it's time to cool them down so what
we're gonna do is bust out some of the
most ridiculous Nouveau flavored ice
cream that New York has to offer
so we're cooling it down we get to eat I
bringing it up and then now we're
cooling it down I like it so what we'll
do is try to guess the flavor how are
you making fun of us we are not if I
were making fun of you maybe I'd say
something like which creme is the dream
let's talk about blindfolds please
please okay I'm into this all right here
you guys go
don't touch the inside of your blindfold
don't touch the inside of your blindfold
all right so ice cream flavor number one
I didn't look at the color of it it's
got a melon flavor
I was kind of getting some banana
[Music]
horrible oh yeah oh it's a it's a it's a
it's open what's wrong with you man it's
just ice cream it's a banana
it's a it's a type of banana dish that's
got bananas in it but it's not banana
chum burger what are we eating a banana
grave a Morgan's what would you give me
all right one more ice cream to go is it
the best will it wear the crown we'll
find out now is it there it's there all
right
here we are Oh
[Music]
brilliant idea this is a durian mm-hmm
this is durian oh this is durian I can
taste it right away I like direct route
not big into the durian but when your
mouth's on fire any port in a storm and
look at you rhettandlink all the way
through the hot ones gauntlet was
nothing left to do
whoo but roll out the red carpet for you
guys this camera this camera or this
camera lets people know what you have
going on in your life gosh what do we do
now
we're rhettandlink digital influencers
you can catch us on the website youth w
wh TT p :
4/4 /ww youtube.com slash good mythical
more
I'd like to that camera the whole time
you say something to Shawn's camera
we're at an Lake I'm speaking into
Shawn's camera
Shawn's cameras getting uncomfortable
HTTP it's the new crane / / /
www.youtube.com / good mythical morning
you can also get there if you go to
youtube.com / right and link to but
that's confusing don't do that
oh that's fine that was varying with
rancid million to 1 million three that's
pretty good form Phil then you get that
cool shirt
you didn't hear how ones merch it's
available now I thought you only wore
Where's Waldo shirts I used to wear
Where's Waldo shirts
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
one
you
[Music]